Hey guys, and welcome to a brand new
video. Today we're back with another
1hour flipping challenge. Today's
category is going to be uh magic. So
that could be any magical items, magical
staves or staffs if that's what you
prefer. Uh magical equipment and runes
or anything else related to magic. I
have 60 mil here to work with today and
we're going to see how much money I can
make in 1 hour. So let's get started.
Start the timer and let's go. So first
up, I have G Tracker loaded up here with
the highest margin page. And once again,
G Tracker is a sponsor of mine, just so
you're aware. There will be a link in
the description. You can sign up for an
account uh if you feel like this would
be useful for you. Uh so yeah, first up,
we have a bunch of items here. Let's see
if any are magic related. Here is the
rims armor set. Uh now, a lot of people
ask me all the time, how do you use G
Tracker properly? Because of course,
these are not going to be perfectly
accurate by the minute uh prices, but
you still you kind of use them for a
general understanding and see if the
item might have a good margin on it. So,
I would say that looks pretty good.
We'll go ahead and price check in a rims
rope or rim set, sorry. All right. So,
we bought it
for
2583 and we're going to sell it back
2478 and the limit on this is 8. Uh, so
we'll go ahead and do uh we'll give it a
try for seven right now. Another nice
easy one is death runes. Uh 3GP on this
one. And for the video, I do undercut on
the buy price just because honestly, if
I'm going to get anything done, there
won't be enough time for me to do this
in an hour. Um, but the buy limit on
these is 10,000. So, we're going to do
just a little bit under uh 10,000 96.
And that'll be an easy 30k. Nothing too
extraordinary. Uh, but not too bad. All
right, another easy 3GP margin on there.
Going to do about the same thing. 9995
on the blood room. Really quick to buy,
easy to do. All our death runes are
almost through pretty much already. Nice
and quick. Let's just toss in the L rune
as well, just to get these out of the
way early. That one has a 7GP margin on
it right now. Uh really nice from the L
rune. All right, I may try buying one
Master Wand uh for maybe
490. Uh we'll give it a try to buy.
Maybe it'll come through. Try 5,1K. And
we'll try to buy one of those for now.
Uh all the runes have come through
already. So death runes. Uh we'll just
go ahead and recheck the price here. All
right, selling death runes back for a
30k profit. It's something. Uh, law
runes all the way through already. Sell
the law runes off for 242. It looks like
that has a gray margin than law runes.
For some reason, laws tend to have a
better margin than a lot of the other
runes often. Okay, another quick item
could be the rims rope skirt. Another
magical item and uh well, we'll just
price check it just because it should
come through quick enough and shouldn't
be too big of a loss. So, 1080. That's a
bit higher than I thought it was going
to be. And into 990. Oh wow. Uh so let's
do
99.95k and we'll definitely do as many
of these as possible. It looks like
let's try eight. Okay, at least we
finally have a item that's coming
through. Nice, which is the rims rope
skirt. Bought them from 995. We're going
to sell them for 1080. So try selling
them for
1075k. Uh sell one of those off. We got
one so far, which is nice. And the other
things are selling off. Haven't bought
either of these two yet, but there's
still time, of course. And the last item
I'm going to do is the uncharged toxic
trident. Uh should be a very quick item.
If we go down to the graph here, it
looks like quite a number traded every
even 10 minutes. So, we'll go ahead and
try that item. Toxic
uh trident. I think we want the
uncharged one. Probably doesn't matter
too much. And wow, it's actually a
really decent margin on these items. Uh,
we'll try him for
371k and that's going to be pretty much
the rest of our money. We'll do seven.
And there we go. We invested everything
pretty much. Okay, so we bought all the
blood runes finally for 213. We'll go
ahead and sell those off. And first of
all, we're going to price check, of
course. And we're selling them for 216.
And we bought them all for 213. So,
we're going to continue to get a 3GB
margin on that. Okay, there we go. We
sold off in the rims rope skirt. Kind of
breaking even on that margin. And now we
just have to buy a couple more of those.
Uh, it took a while, a little bit longer
to come through than I thought it would.
Okay, we have an uncharged trident
coming through for
3148. Kind of running out of spots here,
but I'll I'll toss in here for now. I
guess maybe something will clear up by
the time everything comes through. Okay,
we got a second room's rope skirt coming
through. And I think at this point I'm
going to
pull Oh, I don't know. These haven't
come through at all, which is a little
unfortunate. And neither have uh the
master
wand, but I think I'm going to pull the
master wand out. Nah, let's pull this
out. There's a lot more money here. And
we're going to dump them for how much
again? 1075. That's a pretty good
margin, actually. Not too bad at all.
1075. All right, we've sold all the
blood runes off. That is a 30k profit.
Nothing too great, but did clear up
another offers lot, which is nice. Okay,
and a few seconds later, we sold off
another Arim's robe skirt uh for a
little bit less, but we had to drop the
margin a bit because it wasn't selling.
Another one of these coming through, but
we haven't sold a single one yet. So,
we're probably going to reduce them down
a bit. Okay, so we finally sold a
uncharged Dr. Trident for
3126. And we may have actually bought
another one as well. Looks like we have
not buying and selling nearly as quick
as I thought they would. Uh actually
very surprised about that cuz it's a
very heavily used item. I thought it
would come through quicker, but maybe
it's because it's the uncharged version
and people are lazy and don't want to
fill it up. That is possible as well.
Okay, looks like we sold another
uncharged toxic trident. So, we're going
to go ahead and pop it in here for 3126
as well. And I think we bought another
uh a rims rope skirt. So, that's two of
those. Uh pop those in for
1067. I'm definitely fighting with
someone on this. Uh so, we'll just pop
him down a bit. That must be why it's
coming through slower. 1067 and got
another one of those as well. We'll have
to adjust that again. Okay, the Sears
ring has a 17k game margin on it, which
really is pretty good. I mean, we'll do
eight of these. That's not a big deal. I
guess we'll do seven. And they should
come through reasonably quickly. Okay,
we sold off both of the rope skirts.
That's nice. And we just had a couple
more come through. Uh, which is okay.
They all came through awesome. I think
we're going to do a couple more of these
items. The rim sets seem to be treating
us very nicely. selling them for 1067.
Any more money to come in? Doesn't look
like it. Uh we did reduce the both the
runes. They just were not selling at all
and they seem to be coming through now.
So I went to go try and buy an Arim's
robe top. It seemed like it would be
good. And I bumped it up a bunch and
didn't even buy for 1,400. So I decided
to just go ahead and try to buy one for
a reasonable price instead of losing a
bunch of money price checking it. Uh
1285. heavy. I mean, if it possibly
could sell for uh 1,400, that would be
insane. 1286 and we'll just start with
one just in case I insta buy it. Good.
Didn't uh now actually looks like we've
sold quite a bit of stuff. So, let's go
recap quickly. Death runes. Uh didn't
make much on that. Rope skirts. Uh we
made 70k on each one and we've done uh
let's see here. Five and then a couple
more. So, we probably made close to 600k
on the item, which is great. Okay, so we
did end up actually buying one for 1286
uh while we were looking for another
item. So, we'll go ahead and I don't
even know what I could try selling this
for. Uh let's try
1449K cuz I bumped it up to actually
1480 and it didn't sell or I didn't buy
it. Sorry. Okay, so we did actually sell
the rims rope top for 1449. That is
crazy. That's a good That's a good flip.
Can't if I do say so myself. Uncharged
Dr. Trident. The last one came through
and uh we don't really have a huge space
issue now. So, we'll just pop it in
here. Okay, for 3124. And we did put
another offer in for more of the rope
tops whenever they do come through. Uh
we can hopefully get the same margin for
whatever reason. Haven't bought a single
one of these. Now, I have the tormented
bracelet uh open here, and I'm still a
little tormented by the um sorry uh by
the purchase I made for my main account.
Was going to be a good purchase, but it
went from 15 mil to 10 mil in a very
short amount of time, but I think I'll
put the offer in
for somewhere around 10 mil. Let's try
10 049K. and we'll try buying one of
these and hopefully we actually can
profit off of it this time. We're also
going to take just a minute here to put
in some astro runes. A 4gp flip. Not too
bad. And uh 10,000 of those is easy to
do. So it looks like the trident of the
seas full has exactly a 50k margin on
it. Uh so we'll put in for 10 51k and
we're going to do as many as we can
which I believe is seven. I didn't
actually check anything for this. I'm
just kind of going through magic items I
know and I know this will buy and sell
very quickly. Okay, so another kind of
highle item that I kind of totally
forgot about is the eternal boots. Let's
get them open on GRA. I was trying to
remember what are some like highly used
magic items and that is clearly the
eternal boots. I think at this point we
just price check this item because it
should flip very quickly and the margin
will always be changing. Uh so it looks
10 4050 to 4061. Nothing crazy right
now. Let's go ahead and check the
eternal boots bought for
4150 and uh we're going to sell for
actually that might be a pretty big
margin. No, but still nothing better to
do. Uh easy money if we go ahead. I can
see people slowly battling it up. Uh so
we'll just use the rest of our money
here cuz we have a lot sitting around
and seven is hidden limit anyway. Okay,
so we bought five of these seven seers
rings and we only well we're over
halfway. Not anything terrible, but I
don't want to be stuck with them this
whole time and I think they may be the
longest to sell out of all these items.
Next up, I'm probably going to dump
these guys in because they should sell
reasonably quickly. Uh we bought them or
sold them for 1,100, bought them for,00
whatever. We'll try keeping that margin
even though
that's probably not the case. We'll give
it a try though. Okay, we did manage to
sell one of the Trenton of the seas and
we bought three more and I think that'll
be good for now. We are going to have to
kind of keep in mind that we do have to
sell all these. Uh, so
1097. Oh, that's too cheap.
1096 and five of those. Wow. I am still
extremely surprised that we managed to
sell the rims rope top for such a
margin. Let's just calculate that
because I'm bored and I don't have much
else to do besides wait. Now,
1449 minus 1286 is 163. And I'm pretty
sure we've done at least three of these,
maybe even four, but I think three.
That's almost 500k just off this item.
Uh, so I'm pretty happy with how that's
going so far. Okay, so we bought all of
the astral runes finally for 141.
Probably just in time, too, because uh
we're getting pretty close to the end
here. We can sell them for 145, which
would be about a 40k profit, hopefully.
Okay, so we finished selling off all the
law runes. I think we just broke even on
that at best. Nothing too great here. We
got another rope top coming through. And
once again, we're going to try to get
that 167k margin on it. Okay, so we have
quite a few buy offers uh continuing to
come through. The eternal boots.
Actually, we bought three more of those.
We did sell them for 4135, which is
okay, I guess. 15k on each one isn't
that great, but we'll sell it off anyway
for about the same price.
Just a second ago, all the rims rope
tops came through. So, that is a little
frightening because I think uh they
don't sell that
quickly. Let's reduce it down a little
bit and hope uh they sell a little bit
quicker than they have been. You know
what? I changed my mind. I just sold one
really quickly for 1399. I'm going to
pop them back in there for what they
were before, which is
1449. Uh since we do have 16 minutes
left, we have sold off all the astro
runes, which is awesome. That is going
to
be 40k profit on that. Uh the uncharged
trident all sold off. That was I think
about 50k each of those. And I think we
flipped all seven kind of minus one for
checking the margin. Uh leaves us with
300k on that roughly. Trident of the
seas just came through for 1096.
Uh, we got 50k in each of those and
flipped
like probably 250k or 300k in profit
worth of these as well. So, this is
actually going
marvelously. 35 mil, but only 15 minutes
left. Not sure if I should spend this or
not. Okay. Surprisingly, out of all the
three, we sold the rims rope top
quickest. Uh, can't say how happy I am
with this item. Uh, we did at least six.
Uh, atund at least
150 is 900k from this item alone. I
think I'm primed to be making close to 2
mil. I I would have to guess. 12 mil
left. Honestly, I don't really want to
do anything that might this up. So,
I'm probably just going to wait for
these items to sell and then just kind
of end it. Okay, we sold off all the
eternal boots. Nah, not great, but still
reasonably quick, but not really good
for uh the cost. Uh Sears rings are
almost all sold. Just one more to go. We
got 8 minutes left, so I'm just going to
leave it, guys. Okay, guys. There we go.
Sears ring has been sold off. 320k
getting added. Let's see where we're at
now. Looks like we did break the 2 mil
mark. Uh which I think is really good
for how much money we started with. I
think we got some really good margins,
especially on the Barrows items. Let's
go ahead and check our total. All right,
looks like we just squeezed by uh
2.05 mil in profit. Uh not bad for an
hour's work. Did get a little lucky on
some of the barrows items and but
overall this category very good. You can
get very good margins on it pretty
consistently and I would give it a try
uh if you have the money to spare. All
right guys, thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next video.
[Music]